Hi, everyone. This
is the question
review for CNS
infections.
So in the first question,
we have a 17-year
-old female brought to
the ED with a headache,
stiff neck, and
sensitivity to light.
Temperature 102,
blood pressure 100 over
70, and heart
rate of 140.
Blood test and
CSF obtained a
polymorphonuclear
nucleosides, increased
protein, and
decreased glucose.
gram stain revealed
the presence of gram
positive diplococci
resistant to penicillin she
was promptly started on
medication and within
minutes a flushing
of her face and upper
body was noted so
what's the mechanism of
action of this drug so
the the symptoms that
she presents with The
CSF is consistent with
bacterial meningitis,
and she was also told,
we're told, that it's a
gram-positive diplocoxide
resistant to penicillin.
So this looks
like it's a MRSA infection,
and the medication
caused her to have
flushing in the face.
So with that gram
-positive infection,
we know that Vanco is
going to be included.
And I said with Vanco,
first of all, it's
going to bind to the
D-alanine subunit.
That's its mechanism.
The resistance
is that D-alanine
can be changed
to D-lactate.
And then I mentioned a
couple of toxicities.
Among them was
otonephrotoxicity, which
can be a problem with
aminoglycosides, so
you have to do the
dosing very carefully.
And if you don't infuse
this at a slow rate,
what you will have
is an increase in
histamine, and that can
lead to this condition
known as Redman syndrome.
so the best thing
is to infuse slowly
and maybe pre-treat
with a dose of
diphenhydramine the histamine
blocker so looking at
the choices binding
to ergosterol that is
going to be considered
the drug of choice
for somebody that has
crypto and this is the
mechanism of amphotericin.
She doesn't have
fungal meningitis.
Binding of the D
-alanine subunit, that's
probably going to
be the best answer.
Inhibition of protein
synthesis at the
30S ribosome, that
could either be a
tetracycline or an
aminoglycoside where
aminoglycosides inhibit
the initiation and
tetracyclines inhibit
the elongation.
14-alpha-D
-methylase is going
to be true of
those drugs that
are known as
azole antifungals.
So fluconazole,
itraconazole.
Fluconazole is used
with meningitis
because it's lipophilic.
Viral DNA
polymerase, that was
probably a no
because this is not a
viral meningitis.
We are told that
there is presence
of a bacteria.
And then inhibition
of DNA gyrus, that
would be something that
would not cause this
issue. And we could
say that the one
that they use most for
meningitis conditions
is the moxifloxacin.
With fluoroquilinolones,
I would expect
more of a tendon
rupture. It would
be not indicated in
pregnancy or pediatric
pediatric populations.
So,
you know, again,
17 would mean that
we would have to
do a risk versus
benefit because
growth does stop at 18
and 18 is usually
the time where
fluoroquinolones
oral can be started.
But we're dealing
with Redman syndrome.
So the best answer
is going to be
this one. It is
definitely vancomycin.
So B is correct.
So vanco binds to the
D-alanine subunit. I
did speak briefly
about cycloserine being
used for multi-drug
resistant tuberculosis,
but that's not the
case here. And then the
penicillins, they block
this enzyme, which
is responsible for
the cross-linking of
the peptidoglycan cell
wall so if you don't
have this the cell
wall does not get rigid
and eventually it just
that's it dies and
you can't get replication
so remember with
meningitis these drugs
are used oftentimes
first line because
they're bacteriocidal.
You do empiric, so you
want to start the drug
right away and, you
know, then pending
culture. You want to
have something on board.
And you want something,
because you're
doing empiric, you
want something that
can cover both
positive and negative.
And I said that the
third generation
cephalosporins are
especially important
because they can
cross the blood-brain
barrier because
they are lipophilic.
What you would use for
resistance could
be linezolid,
deptomycin, ceftaroline,
or quinipristin,
and dalfopristin
would be another
option for VRE.
Okay, so that's a
little bit about that.
And then the other use
for oral vanco, because
you want to get to
the source of the GI,
would be to treat C.
difficile infections.
So this 20-year-old
presented to the ED with
fever, headache, and
sensitivity to light.
A lumbar
puncture revealed
polymorphonuclear
leukocytes, increased
protein, and
decreased glucose.
He was administered
an IV antibiotic after
admission, so they
did empiric therapy,
most likely with a
third-gen cephalosporin.
the family was told
they must receive
treatment because they
had close contact with
this patient which of
the following could
be expected from the
use of this drug by the
family members so
we're looking here at
adverse effects so
first of all if we're
talking about prophylaxis
that's important
because we do want to
consider the people that
are living with this
patient whether it
be in the home in a
dorm, in the military.
And we said that
the one that
is used is going
to be rifampin.
And this is going to
rev up metabolism of
other drugs. It's an
inducer. It's going
to ultimately target
RNA and it causes,
like the color here,
red secretions, which
is not a harmful
effect. It's actually
showing that the patient
is being compliant.
So we have crystal
urea, this would be
specific to aciclovir
and maybe a sulfonamide,
which we didn't discuss
in this lecture.
Elevated creatinine
levels, that could
be an aminoglycoside
or even amfotericin.
Okay, I'm just doing side
effects, not antibiotics.
Hearing loss
could be something
like Banco or the
aminoglycosides.
Photosensitivity, in
this lecture, we can
talk about the tetracyclines
can cause this,
the fluoroquinolones, and
even the sulfonamides.
This is the best answer,
red-orange secretions,
and then tendon rupture,
I would be most concerned
with fluoroquinolones.
So E is going
to be the best
answer for this question.
and this is going to
inhibit dna dependent
rna polymerase aside
from that if you
get a resistance
remember when we talk
about antibiotics or
anything that binds
an enzyme the the
one thing you can
say that any resistance
can be a mutation
in that enzyme and
that's going to be
true of this specific
one with rifampin.
Rifampin is part of
ripe therapy, which
we will discuss next
year when we do the
drugs for mycobacterium
tuberculosis.
This 37-year-old
female was hospitalized
and treated for
meningitis caused by
gram-negative bacilli
with several drugs.
Within 72 hours,
the patient noted
an elevation in
BUN and creatinine.
What's the cause
of this change?
So,
BUN and creatinine
are going to be
specifically to check
our renal function. So we
can safely say that
this drug used for
gram-negative is going
to alter renal function.
so looking at the
choices first of all
I would probably say
that fluconazole is
a no because it's
not treating bacteria
ampicillin would
be broad spectrum
it would possibly
be for listeria it
would not raise
BUN and creatinine
ceftriaxone is
going to be for
third generation
cephalosporin
use, it's lipophilic.
We would not
be so concerned
with renal, with
septriaxone.
Chloramphenicol
is going to be 50S
and it binds the
peptidyl transferase.
Chloramphenicol is
not kidney, it's going
to be mainly liver,
it's glucloronidated and
that's the reason
why you get the gray
baby syndrome because
you're missing UDP
cofactor as a neonate and
the drug would accumulate
and cause cyanosis
and hypotension and
the cyanosis makes
the baby appear gray.
So gentamicin is in
fact the best answer.
One of the more
nephrotoxic drug classes
especially when we
talk about antibiotics
and GENT is going
to stop initiation
so by binding
covalently to the
30s you're shutting
down the whole idea
of protein synthesis
and also under
30S, you get
misreading of the cold.
The drug concentrates
in the proximal
tubule and what you
might see happen
with the aminoglycosides
is you can get
changes in the
lysosomes where you get
spillage of the
contents and there may
be ROSs that form
in the mitochondria
and that changes
the energy dynamics.
If you're taking other
nephrotoxic drugs,
this is a problem. But
one thing about this
class is that when
the drug is removed,
that would mean that
the action still
continues because
the drug still works
even when the concentration
goes below the
minimum inhibitory
concentration, the
MIC, and that enables
you to dose it
once a day or sometimes
even every two
days. I've even seen
every three days,
depending on the
patient's renal function.
And by decreasing
acetylcholine,
you will affect
muscle contraction.
and ototoxicity
unlike nephro which is
reversible ototoxicity
is irreversible
so that the drug
now accumulates and
there's going to be
production of free
radicals in the inner
ear and it's especially
true when you add
on another ototoxic
drug like cisplatin
which is a cancer
drug or a loop diuretic
like furosemide.
This is a 29-year
-old female presenting
to the physician
with complaints
of fatigue, weakness,
and shortness
of breath. Her
gums are bleeding.
On exam, she's pale.
Her blood pressure
is 120 over 80 with
a pulse of 150.
She was recently
in the hospital
to treat bacterial
meningitis.
In the labs, you can
see that her red blood
cells are low, her
white blood cells are
low, and her platelets
are low. So this is
explaining the fatigue.
The gums bleeding
is explaining the the
low platelets so this
is looking like a bone
marrow suppression
effect and if we're
talking about bacterial
meningitis looking at
the choices we have
to say to ourselves
what can this be so we
can look at the mechanism
binding to the d
-alanine subunit this
is vanco i would say
no maybe you'd get
ototoxicity maybe nephro
and you would get
the red man syndrome
inhibition of protein
synthesis at the 30s
we don't know which
one it is if it's like
tetracycline you would
think of azotemia you
might think photosensitivity
**** staining
but not a change
in bone marrow
or development
of blood cells.
Inhibition of
DNA-dependent RNA
polymerase, that
is rifampin, so you
can get red
secretions, revving up
metabolism, maybe
some liver tox.
And then we're left
with inhibition of
peptidyl transferase
and inhibition of
transpeptidase. And
E is going to be the
beta-lactams. So with
beta-lactams, you
might expect some
interstitial nephritis.
Or in rare cases,
there can be
anaphylaxis with
a 1% to 2% cross
-reactivity with
the other drugs.
It's not going to
change your blood cells.
I did say cefmandol
can cause bleeding
because it imitates in
mechanism that structure
can have vitamin k
epoxide inhibition
but it would not do
anything else with
respect to lowering red
blood cells or white
blood cells so this
is chloramphenicol
and we said that
chloramphenicol aside from
the gray baby syndrome,
it could cause a
degree of changing
what's happening in the
bone marrow. Because
protein synthesis
inhibition in the bone
marrow might affect
the mitochondria and
that can affect the
energy in those cells,
energy production in
those cells. So D is
the best answer. The
answer is chloramphenicol,
and that is
what's causing the bone
marrow suppression.
So Rickettsia meningitis
can happen, mainly
that's due to the fact
that you're exposed
to some type of
organism, an animal,
basically. And
chloramphenicol, even though
it's bacteriostatic,
it's very lipophilic.
So it can get across
and treat various
organisms that are
involved in meningitis.
The idea here with
Rickettsia, by
the way, you can
use chloramphenicol,
but doxy is usually the
one that is preferred.
Okay, so there we
go. Those are the
adverse effects of
chloramphenicol.
A 56-year-old female
with a history of
type 2 diabetes was
hospitalized and
treated for meningitis
with several drugs.
While the patient
did recover from
the infection, an
increase in her
fasting glucose
levels was observed.
If this was due to a
specific treatment,
which is the cause? so
we did say there is a
role of glucocorticoids
in supportive care
it can help reduce
hearing loss it can help
with some of the swelling
that patients may
get especially with
the viral meningitis
so looking at here the
the answer choices i'm
going to vote that
dexamethasone is the
right choice. Okay.
These other drugs would
not affect the glucose
levels. Okay. Like
fluconazole can affect
hepatocytes, neomycin,
again, the kidney,
the ears, the balance.
And Van Gogh could
cause the redness
and also odor and
nephrotoxicity.
with giving these
medications they would
be very short term
by the way and I will
mention that glucocorticoids
start everything
from the beginning
so if you're cutting
arachnidonic acid
synthesis you're not
going to create
prestaglandins that are
responsible for
inflammation or leukotrienes
which are responsible
for bronchospasm.
Okay and then in
between you have the COX
enzymes and those are
going to be blocked by
NSAIDs and the LOX
will be inhibited by
ziluton and there are
some drugs here that will
block the leukotriene
receptors and then
of course thromboxane
which is involved in
platelet aggregation
is blocked by aspirin.
okay but again this drug
class works on nuclear
transcription so what
will happen is that
the drug comes in the
receptor dissociates
from heat shock proteins
the instability now
allows a dimerization,
that continues in
the nucleus and that
increases transcription.
With respect to
the side effects,
less than 14 days
we should be okay,
but more than 14
days we would expect
enhanced gluconeogenesis,
which is probably
the reason why this
type 2 diabetic is
getting poor control
of her diabetes.
You can get increase
in osteoclast, which
breaks down bone,
decrease in vitamin D
which will prevent calcium
from being absorbed
and then you have
effects on growth
and you also have an
effect on blood pressure
because these drugs
allow for sodium
and water to be
recovered and you also
get in the middle with
metabolics you get
like a stomach that
forms central obesity
but your arms and
legs become more
thin and that's due
to muscle atrophy.
A 50-year-old male
with a history
of HIV was evaluated
in the clinic
for confusion,
blurred vision,
headache, and a
temperature of 101.
A lumbar puncture
was done and an
analysis of the
cerebral spinal fluid
revealed the presence
of cryptococcal
antigen. He was
admitted into the
hospital and
medication was started.
Very shortly after,
he complained of
feeling hot and cold,
which is the cause.
So with Crypto, he
was probably given
three medications, most
likely Amphotericin
and Flucidazine
and Fluconazole.
And when you inject
Amphotericin, what will
happen is you're going
to get an increase
in prostaglandins and
that's going to lead
to this shake and
bake which again is
attributed to first aid
and the way we manage
amphoterrible and
that's sometimes a word
that we would say
among ourselves is by
number one for the
kidney is the hydration
but you want to give a
prostaglandin inhibitor
So that can mean an
NSAID, but again,
if you're worried
about kidney,
NSAIDs may not be
the perfect one for
you. You may do
better with, say,
a drug like
acetaminophen, Tylenol.
Aciclovir, keep
hydrated because
you can cause
crystallization in
the urine and
that can cause
obstruction, but
that's used for viral.
doxycycline is
frequently eliminated
but this is again
a tetracycline
so watch for
chelation of your
iron your magnesium,
your calcium
fluconazole, if
anything you might worry
about inhibition of SIP
so if you have other
drugs on board this
inhibition can raise
the levels there's also
some degree of liver
being affected okay so
you would watch liver
function test flucytosine
makes a metabolite
known as 5-fluorouracil
or 5-FU and that's
going to affect
pyrimidines and that's
going to affect DNA
synthesis and to an extent
RNA and protein
synthesis and then lastly
vanco is for MRSA
gram positive it's not
going to be used for
crypto so probably b and
c and b d and e are
used for this condition
but the one that's
causing the shake and
bake is going to be the
amphotericin okay and
as i mentioned this
is something that you
should go through if
we were talking about
microtubules i would
think of grisiofolvin,
you know, amphotericin
and nystatin,
they bind to
ergosterol, they create
fenestirations or
pores and everything
leaks out. And
that could be
what's happening in
the tubules. Okay.
And not only that,
there's some basal
constriction that can
reduce blood flow and
glomerular filtration
rate. And I mentioned
with the loss of
these ions, especially
if we're talking
about potassium
calcium and sodium that
can affect the action
potentials of the
heart so that's why
with that board question
that i mentioned
in the lecture it was
pointing towards a
cardiac toxicity but
don't be confused
this is not affecting
the heart it's
affecting the ions which
regulate the heart.
And then again,
with respect to
giving in a
liposome, remember
a liposome is
going to bypass
like for example
here, the kidney,
it's going to
go right to the
fungal cell and
do the damage that
it needs to kill
the cryptococcus.
So liposomes are
really nice. They do
it also for doxorubicin
where that drug
looks to for the
cancer cell to do the
damage there. So the
cardiac cells which
are a target for
doxorubicin will be
spared. So that's just
a little bit about
amphotericin.
Thank you all for
your attention.
I hope you have
a great day.
Let me know if you
have any questions.
Be well and I'll
see you soon.